Here I have a square
with a height, say, 1 meter.
This is the height here.
It's 1 meter.
Let's say his width is also 1 meter.
I'm talking about the size of the whole square,
not just the colored part.
This is also 1 meter.
How many will be the face of the whole square,
and not just the colored part? On the whole square?
Okay, the common face
will be equal to
height in width.
1 meter 1 meter.
1 in 1 of course is 1,
meters per meter
we can record as a square meter
or square meter as you choose.
With this in this way,
to focus on the colored part.
Let's think about it.
The colored part
is equal to how much?
I recommend that you stop the video
and try to understand yourself.
Something you might think is,
that whole face, our whole square
is divided into these same rectangles.
One way to think about it,
is what is the face of each of these rectangles?
For example, what is the person
this rectangle here?
To understand this, we can ask ourselves
what part is this from the whole?
So we need to understand
how many such rectangles
the whole thing is divided.
We can try to count them,
or say,
I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10 columns,
and each column has 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7.
So we have 10 columns of 7
or a total of 70 such rectangles,
which divide our whole
in 70 equal parts.
This one here
is 1/70 from the entire face.
So 1/70 of the square meter,
which of course will be equal to 1/70 of the square meter.
This is one of them.
Only one of these rectangles.
If we want to know what the color area is,
we can count how many of these rectangles there are
in it and see that these are 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9 columns
of 1, 2, 3.
So 27 of these rectangles,
of these identical rectangles in the colored part.
The colored part will be
we have 27 of these rectangles and each of them
has a face
1/70
of the square meter.
What does this give us?
This tells us that the face of the colored
part will be equal to 27/70.
27 on 1/70 will be equal to 27/70.
27/70 square meters
and we are ready.
I want to tell you,
that there are several ways,
on which we can solve the problem.
Another way to solve it
is to figure out what the dimensions are
of the colored part.
For example ...
For example, what is the height
only the colored part?
Only this height,
and I recommend that you stop the video
and try to think about the height,
it will be some kind of liver.
Okay, if we move vertically,
we divide this meter.
Divide the meter into 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
I will do it in a different way.
We split it into 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6,
7 equal parts.
This may be a bit confusing,
the way I drew it.
You can see it if you look ...
Actually let me use a brighter color.
We have...
It's hard for me to choose a color.
Okay, here's how.
We have 1 here.
2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7 equal parts to which we have split this meter.
The height of the colored part is 3 of them.
That height here
this height is 3/7 of the total height,
and the whole height is 1 meter.
That's 3/7 of the meter.
By the same logic, what is the width?
What will be the width?
We can see that the whole meter
is divided into 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10 equal parts,
it will be a tenth.
This distance will be tenth.
Let me make it in a different color.
This distance here will be tenth,
but how many dozens represent
the width of the green area?
Let's see we have 1/10, 2/10,
3/10, 4/10, 5/10,
6/10, 7/10, 8/10, 9/10.
This width is 9/10 of the entire length,
which is 1 meter, means 9/10 of the meter.
To find the area,
we can multiply the width to height
or height along the width.
We can say, I'll write it down again.
This colored part.
For the colored part instead of this way
we can say that we have 3/7 of the meter.
So 3/7 meters
and multiply it by our width,
only for the colored part,
which is 9/10 from the meter.
9/10 of the meter.
How much will it give us?
This will be equal to
the meter per meter is equal
per square meter, which we want,
then we can multiply the numerators,
then the denominators.
3 in 9 will give us 27,
and 7 in 10 will give us 70.
Just what we got before.
27/70 of the square meter.
Let me write this a little more orderly.
27/70
of the square meter.
You may want to think why it's coming out exactly,
no matter how we did it.
Note that 3 and 9 are numerators.
This means how many rows and columns we have
of these small rectangles.
A 7 and 10
is to understand exactly how small the rectangle we have.
It's like saying
3 by 9 is the number of rectangles we have.
A 7 in 10 is
part of the whole,
which represents each of these rectangles,
and that's what we did here.
In both ways, you will get a true answer,
but I want you to think why.